as they celebrate three years in
business and here to tell us about the
menu and incredible drinks it's
executive chef Nicole Kinder and
bartender Kate lootweiler welcome you to
thank you happy anniversary first of all
such a great restaurant located on
Valley View and Spring Mountain three
years and you are the one responsible
for the food let's talk about some of
the amazing dishes you have at work well
obviously we're at Taqueria so we do the
tacos we have so many different kinds
that we were located in Chinatown so we
like to put a little bit of we have like
a Taiko Taco which has got crispy beef
and cilantro and cabbage and sweet chili
sauce and then we've got the the [ __ ]
Taco which is like pho and it's in a um
a wonton shell so that's right I love
the fusion the fusion is just perfect
and you're going to have some great
specials to celebrate three years we're
going to talk about that let's talk
about some of the drinks too of course
you got to go with the classic
Margaritas definitely we have our
classic margarita
um this one is going to have Blanco
tequila lime lemon agave and triple sec
oh my gosh I'm already my mouth is
watering between the food I don't know
if we can take a look at some of these
dishes here you guys are going to have
specials too
um celebrating three years this is going
to be great so what kind of specials are
you going to be having so since we're
doing our three year anniversary on
February 7th it's a Tuesday so we're
gonna double it as tacos yes Taco
Tuesday I'm gonna do bottomless tacos uh
for twenty dollars and you get a choice
of flour tortilla corn tortilla you get
chicken Carnitas or ground beef and you
can do cilantro onion or just our
traditional slaw mix oh man and then
seven dollar Margaritas you're about to
try let's try one of these cheers a
happy three year and anniversary you
guys now again we said the location you
said it's in Chinatown what um what
other dishes or what other drinks do you
recommend that people give a shot to um
I would definitely recommend our Great
Balls of Fire this is going to be almost
like a margarita but we put spice and
watermelon in it and it is a house
favorite everyone loves it well this is
amazing already just the classic
margarita I am definitely a fan and
again you guys are having some great
specials what do you want people to know
about the restaurant if you haven't been
before what's something that you want
people to know so it's fun because when
you first walk in all you see is like a
traditional Taqueria and you're you're
like am I in the right place and then
you walk down this hallway which our
host will guide you down and you're just
transformed into our our Lounge area and
it's just like two different worlds
really front and back it's kind of like
a speakeasy
oh man I am a fan three years thank you
guys so much for being a part of this
cheers to three here's to another three
and another three and another three
after that we're gonna toss it